and we at it again
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
your absolutely favorite podcast
you know the name
this is
[Applause]
what's up y'all welcome back to
riverwood ribbon another week
i did shows i did a show at the rose
bowl
driving i did an outdoor show i
i did table reads for the for the show
and you know i'm watching tv and i'm
just living my life and then i come here
and i tell you all
about it so uh thank you for being here
once again
and you know just welcome back to
[Music]
all right welcome back to riffing with
griffin once again we're here
back in riffing with griffin studios uh
live from the west side
west side los angeles so what's up guys
um you know you're here yeah
i know you i got some loyal followers
every time i think i don't want to do
the podcast anymore
somebody will come up to me and be like
oh man love your podcast man
never miss it and i'm like oh i got to
keep doing it
i don't know it's just it's just one of
those things you know this is like 127
episodes i didn't even know i didn't
know what it was going to be
is it good was it going to be smaller
than this way bigger than this
you know what i mean who knows but here
i am i'm doing it keeps me creative
keeps me in the mix
so here we are with him with griffin so
welcome back um once again you're not
game
i'm on air griffin gaming on twitch
daily make sure you check that out
please subscribe share i promise you i'm
i know
it's like i got to figure out patreon
it's like should i do a set like another
episode i mean i barely feel like i feel
like people watch me anyway
even on my own on this so it's like do i
do another episode do i do strictly
i was thinking about doing like like tv
movie reviews
on patreon short episodes and it's just
for patreon members
you know and like you guys tell me like
you go hey
what do you think of this show and then
i'll watch it and then i'll tell you
what i think about it you know for
patreon members
you know something like that i'm trying
to you know i try to i tried to get
rachel and i to do stuff
but then she wanted to do it on her own
channel and then like so we went like i
went to the dentist
her dentist like rachel all her doctors
seem to be attractive like
she goes to this hot chiropractor like
he's too hot to be a
chiropractor in my opinion you know you
see his videos on instagram like my girl
founder found him on tick tock and she
was like oh yeah but she herself told me
he's like oh yeah he's cute
you know and i'm like what do you mean
he's cute let me see then i saw him and
i was like damn he's cute
um dr tyler shout out to him
so that he has a bunch of videos girls
come in you know they're just like
you know they hug him and he's like
cracking them and all this stuff and i
saw him and i was like just dudes too
damn cute
and then like so then rachel's telling
me about her dentist she's like well my
dentist is really attractive and
i told her about you and she's like a
fan and you know so i go well let me go
meet your dentist
so but i actually did go meet the
dentist and she was very lovely but
she's married with kids
but that was our joke where rachel you
know we went into office and i said well
rachel said you were the only person i
can leave her for
you know we just that's just how we joke
which is funny uh but yeah so i got my
den
my teeth cleaned because i hadn't gone
for a whole year
like i went to got a really deep
cleaning before
um the pandemic hit and then i couldn't
go back to the dentist because it's
weird to go to the dentist because you
can't wear a mask
at the dentist if you're one of these
like really like
germaphobe people that are like i mean
everyone around me has to wear a mask
then you ain't going to the dentist
okay because you have to wear you know
it's stupid it's actually ridiculous
you know so you know they make you take
i mean i have like
i'm down doing the show and they're
gonna make an announcement so
i think it's cool for me to just say it
doesn't matter what the name of this
show is called bucktown it's on abc i
haven't been fired yet
you know this is how it works show
hasn't been picked up it's just a pilot
you know
so but you know so they they started
covet testing so i have to like do all
like every three days somebody comes to
your place
uh and they do the swab you know then
then you get like the the information
that comes to your you know your phone
so i've already done two and then like
so i got the
the test results and then i had like
shows to do
but it was great because i had this
result so i told my dentist
i said to her i was like look let me
show you my covet results
it's just something about that like when
you have covid results
handy you know it's it's you feel that
strength of like
that that like an std test you know
i don't know how many times how many how
many of you got an std test but you know
you get to test
and you do something about you that
feels you feel invincible that's when
you want to go challenge it you know as
soon as you get a std test you're ready
to go like
let's i'm ready to raw dog i'm safe you
know
so it's the same kind of thing with the
covet test you just feel like i'm ready
to breathe on people
so i showed um the doctor and then when
i went to i had this show at the rose
bowl for the comedy store
same thing you know you were supposed to
take a cover test and i was like yo look
here's my results from last night i took
it yesterday and they gave me the
results last night so this is this
morning
you can see i'm freaking negative
and i have the vaccine shot
my first one of the fisa i took the
pfizer i don't know the difference
i guess the johnson johnson is just one
shot but i don't know the difference
between the madonna and the pfizer i'm a
little anxious about taking my second
shot because i hear people have had side
effects
like it really hit him hard so now i'm
like oh man is this gonna hit me hard
you know
so i don't know i'm like nervous about
the second shot but my parents took the
second shot and they didn't have any
side effects like that so
who knows maybe i'll be the one to
finally get sick when the you know
a thumb will start growing out of my
forehead or something but
um yeah so i went to the dentist i got
cleaning i
actually turned out i had like a very
very small cavity which really pissed me
off because
the last time i went to the dentist he
was like oh man your teeth are great
i won't be surprised if you if not if
you ever get a cavity everything's gonna
be fine
cut to a year later in quarantine the
doctor's like yeah you got a
little small cavity so she had to put a
filling because my
bite changed too so i got this little
filling and it's like made my bite
i don't know i think it just happens
over time or your jaw
adjusts or something so there was like
like i just woke up one day and i was
like i couldn't chew properly and i was
like what the hell is going on
but i couldn't go to the dentist because
it was right in the middle of the
pandemic so i um
you know she put like a filling or
something that also
that made it so like my bite so i'm used
to it now so
i don't know i'm just rambling about
nonsense in my life right now so i went
to the dentist then i had a great show i
went to the rose bowl i had these great
shows like frank castillo
frank castillo good buddy of mine eliza
schlesinger jeff
ross we're on the show uh candace
thompson
um yeah so we did a show at the rose
bowl you know in front of cars i hated
every
second of it it's so bizarre i don't
like drive-in shows
sorry i don't like looking at people in
their cars
look you know then you could just see
then you kind of like you
there's like class warfare because you
go oh look there's a mercedes and
there's a ford festiva there's
you know you just you start to be like
okay what are all these people doing
together
it's just and then like you can't really
hear the laughter and then uh
they had like they had like boom mics in
near the cars but then you were hearing
yourself in the speaker so you had to
ignore that
and i'm about timing i'm about like i
say something and i need to see the
reaction and feed off that energy
so it's different it's a different type
of animal
um doing a driving show it's not my
favorite but we did it
you know as we get close to normal then
i did another outdoor show
last night too just outdoor show which
was fine it's just outdoor shows
is what it is like you know it's always
like here comes a siren you know here
comes the cars be you know
honking horns and you know and then it's
like it's a little cold and you know so
it's just this whole sort of like
hipstery thing that it's gonna turn into
like i think
when people continue to still do shows
outside it's gonna be like a hipstery
type of feel to it so
i don't know and then we had um a couple
table reads
for the show um which was which is cool
and again it's so bizarre and weird
because they're doing it over zoom
you know so i think we finally go like i
have to address i have to
get a fitting tomorrow i believe it is
no no
tuesday monday or tuesday yeah tuesday i
think i have to get a fitting
so that would be tomorrow if you're
listening to this right now
and i have to get a fitting because you
know i lost weight you know what i mean
like i really i really been working on
my health
um partly because of also booking the
show and i felt like oh i got to
maintain
and just for the fact of simple fact is
like tan 50 is around the corner and i
just
want to be in shape better shape not
inch i don't think i'll ever be in shape
you know if for what we think in our
head of in shape
like a six-pack or something like that
like i don't know if that can ever
happen but i'd like to be healthy
and [ __ ] i like to feel confident with
my shirt off on my honeymoon
i mean that's really my goal with rachel
like if we go to bora bora or something
like that i just i just want to be able
to have my shirt off on the beach and
feel good about it
not that feel good like this nonsense
about feel good about yourself no
no no no i don't want people looking at
me being like look check that dude out
take that fat dude out uh you know being
all confident no no no
i want it to be like you don't even it's
just you don't even think about it just
like oh yeah it's okay for that guy to
have his shirt off
it's like it's not even a thought
there's no extra to it it's just like oh
yeah yeah
it's just a guy at the beach with a
shirt off with his young wife you know
whatever
as opposed to like oh man you know i
don't i don't need any like
i don't i don't need to be i don't need
to cosign because that's what that is
it's the cosign when somebody goes man
you
wow you're really confident in yourself
because they're saying what they're
really saying is
i don't know why you're confident in
yourself because your body looks
terrible
and good and good for you for having it
out in public like that oh that's
inspiring like that
i don't want that you know what i mean i
don't want that so
and taking care of your health is tough
so what i've been doing actually is when
i game
like i play warzone so like if i don't
if only the people that play wars don't
even understand what i'm about to say
but like if i lose a gulag i do five
push-ups and i have like a
exercise cam set up so i have a little
webcam pointed at this corner of the
room
over here and i'll do push-ups and i'll
do like different exercises like you
know
so after every match i'll do like 10
squats but then i give myself like if i
don't get
if i don't achieve certain things in the
game i give myself extra
and so then this then the stream holds
me accountable they're like where are
those push-ups at griff you know it's
all that kind of stuff so
i'm just trying to like you know get
myself um i just want to be healthy
you know what i mean i really just want
to be healthier because at my age you'd
be surprised how easy it is not to be
healthy even when you think you're being
healthy you're not healthy and i'll talk
more about that later with some other
things that i want to talk about but
you know so we had the weird table read
by zoom and then we had you know
i guess they wanted to see how it looked
and then they did it again in front of
the network and it was like an it was by
zoom and it was like
all these there was like like a hundred
people watching or something like that
and we you know we
try to perform our best by zoom it's
just
it's so bizarre i just i really can't
wait for the world to get
back to normal or some semblance of
normal or just
where we feel confident that we could
just be around people
i saw that the ufc is doing a fight in
florida i think i i'm
i think it's jacksonville but i saw dana
white
on uh the president of the ufc or the
owner whatever whatever his title is of
the ufc
so he was on like um partnering no not
partner first take he was on first date
with stephen a smith and uh
max kellerman and you know they were
like hey so it's sold out like
the things sold out in five minutes but
full capacity you know
and they're like well what do you think
about that coronavirus and other stuff
in florida
and he just straight up said he was like
there are 143 cases in
wherever this is going to be apparently
he knew about you know he they had the
research he's like there was only 143
cases
and he's like you know i'm confident in
it it'll be fine
so i mean we're getting it's it's
strange because we're gonna
get to that point we're getting to this
point where it's gonna be like
okay enough already you know i don't
know if that's right or wrong
but we're getting to that point but
there's still gonna be people who
you know have a certain attitude about
it and it's really polarizing i realized
like i ordered some food and the
delivery person came
so that you know i buzz them in because
i live in like a gated off
you know so lady comes i open the door
and she like
sees me she goes uh do you have a mask
just the way she said it i wanted to
like be like
anyway you know and i was like okay here
we go one of these
that's just your that's just how you
think you know what i mean not saying
she's wrong
not saying i'm right okay but that's
just the feeling the sentiment is here
we go
so i just was like oh just leave it
there i closed i just closed the door
because i don't even want to deal with
it i'm not going to get into a
discussion about it
i'm in my house i'm not wearing a mask
in my house okay like
get out of my face that's how i feel
about it like i
i'm when i go out to the public to you
people
and i mean you people and i mean just
the way i said it you people
i i know i have to wear a mask a face
shield in some places and
you know i have to like keep my social
distance and all this stuff but i ain't
doing that at my place
i'm not doing that at home okay because
it's just too much
you know so i just was like yeah just
leave it there close the door on her you
know what i mean
so this is still the reason why i bring
it up is like there's still going to be
people who are going to just be
like they're scared or they just have
this healthy fear
of you know getting sick or whatever
their reasons are
i don't know how long it's going to be
before people like that
feel okay because there were people that
weren't like that
anyway just ocd germaphobe type people
who are you know
people who are like hey i don't shake
hands you know there's already people
that keep their distance
but it's not like some court mandated
thing where like we all have to do this
you know what i mean so you know it was
like that person's choice
so i don't know when we're going to get
back to how long it's going to be when
we could just be normal
or whatever normal means you know we
don't have this thing
and then there's this sort of like you
know do you feel like
vaccine envy or do you feel like
superior when you have the vaccine
you know there's something about that
like i feel like hey i'm vaccinated you
know you
don't come near me or don't don't talk
to me about your nonsense cause i'm
taken care of you know
there's like this feeling because then
there's people who don't want to
you know that don't want to take it too
so then the people that do want to take
it and the people that don't want to
take it like
they you know they're going to be
fighting or are there's going to be
underlying feelings about it
i have friends of mine who are just like
they're just they have a healthy
fear of it i don't know if it's fear but
they just like hey
i'm i'm leery of vaccines and i'm also
leery of the coronaries so i'm gonna
live this way
like i'm doing a show with my buddy ian
edwards and ian
he's the kind of guy he got like a
healthy fear of it like a healthy like
yeah i don't know about the vaccine yet
or i don't know about
uh you know i don't i don't i don't
trust the coronavis so he's not
he's not about going to people's houses
he's not you know he's he's doing
what he needs to do to make sure he
feels safe and everybody around him
feels safe
but we're doing a show together in palm
springs and the guy that runs the show
he hits me up and he says
he hits us up and goes hey um you know
we can now move indoors do you want to
move indoors
you know and i said i don't care but ian
was like let's keep it outside
and i thought to myself at what point is
that gonna be [ __ ]
you know like at what point is it gonna
be like nah
yeah you for the for the people
performing and for the people coming to
the show
because at a certain point people are
going to be like i don't want to sit
outside anymore it's cold
i don't want to just i want to you know
what i mean like when is that going
gonna clash and then what are we gonna
do
when is it gonna come to a head like
that and for someone like ian like when
is it gonna be like yo man
they're not doing outdoor shows anymore
so you're either gonna come inside or
you're not gonna do shows
you know or they're not gonna be enough
shows you know i don't know
who knows where the world is going so
we'll see and i'll keep you posted on
what's happening uh
as the show progresses it's just a fun
thing to be a part of something you know
i feel like i'm working again i feel
like yes
look at me i'm all chill right now
leaning back in my chair
for you people listening you know like
what are you talking about
anyway it's all cool and rachel had this
like crystal
she gave me like when i was doing the
like the last of the tests that i had to
do where i had to like you know
test again and you know booked apart
rachel had this big crystal in here
so now i told her well you can't that
crystal has to stay in the room that
you know that's the energy whether i
believe
in that fufu stuff or not hey you know
it is what it is all right what did i
want to talk about this week for real
i just been rambling about nonsense but
that's riffing with griffin
man i've been watching american idol
um so let's talk about american idol
listen i love american idol i've always
loved american idol but from the
beginning
i really enjoyed it we all loved simon
or you all hated simon or you love to
hate simon
right but there was something about this
british dude
telling it like it is and you didn't
feel like he was just being an [ __ ]
there was something genuine about his
tough love that we all appreciated
so it got to the point where it was like
paul abdul would be like
you know the mom like oh you all did
great
and we're kind of all like okay yeah
yeah okay thanks paula thank you but
simon what do you think because we
wanted to get to the real
i don't know if someone like that a
personality like that the way he was
when he first started
would fly today because we're so i don't
know everybody's so
like weirdly sensitive about everything
everybody's virtue single
singling everybody's like you know
making it out like we're we we all love
everyone and we and we should all be
nice
all the time as you know this is weird
feeling
weird sentiment in the world right now
not to say that we shouldn't all be nice
but it's like
it's not like it's not like genuine
niceness you know i don't know it's just
weirdness going on right now so i don't
know if it would fly but
you know i like uh luke whatever his
name is there's country singer katy
perry
and um lionel richie i think it's a
great mix
great mix of people he's country she's
the pop star
you know uh and lana richie's just a
legend you know
different age ranges so i like these
judges and katy perry is like the simon
really
she really tells her like it is but
there's something that
she's been so successful there's
something that if katy perry is like i
don't think you got it
you go okay i think she has the right to
say i don't think you got it
i think the way she's doing it is like i
like i like her energy about it
she seems genuine they all do you know
they all they all come in
from this sort of like artist
perspective which i can respect
so anyways cut two when the show was
canceled
and then they came back on abc and it's
like here it is now this new version of
the show and then the pandemic hit
but i gotta tell you man this season
they're doing a lot of like
stories about these artists
these kids that come in to perform and
by the way
i don't know what american idol wants to
be sometimes i just go
we're so obsessed with youth we're so
upset
obsessed with youth and beauty is like
the only kind of people we want to see
on tv so a majority of these kids
i don't know why they don't call it teen
american idol just have a whole because
then
because it's always the same thing oh hi
i'm 15. my name's sarah i'm 15 from
tennessee and i've always wanted to sing
you know and it's like 15 year old 16 or
17 year olds 18
it's like all these like young like just
what do they know about anything
people super talented super cute
a majority of them and then and they all
like some of them are like are too
shy this one's too shy and this one's
like you know they're all trying to coax
them to be
you know more than what they are and
then there's these other people that
have these like incredible stories
you know and i find myself
crying while watching american idol
like ridiculous like i'm a big teddy
bear sentimental guy man
no matter how you know i get in your
face about whatever
i'm still a real sensitive dude and i'm
sitting here watching
american idol like and i'm just crying
my eyes out
because it'll show some really good
story and then the person goes on and
sings and then they
sing great and you're just like oh my
god you did it
and it's just really like it's it's
really great
you know like every time like a even
when one of these young kids who i think
is like because
just once i want to see like it's like
hi i'm tina i'm 37 and i've been singing
since i was 20
and then she has the voice of whitney
houston they never have people like that
on the show anymore
you're not gonna see someone like that
they're not looking for the most
talented singer they're actually looking
for like
you know i guess american idol and that
person has to be young or
relatively young and that person has to
be like a phenomenal
you know not even a phenomenal singer
they have to have
all the check boxes for being
a star over talent
so i think this season they're trying to
like
get back to a bigger percentage of
talent
still being a pop star being a celebrity
is still the majority of it but whereas
before i felt it was like
80 20 now they may be at
65 35 you know
maybe maybe more you have to watch you
tell me what you think
so they have these really talented
people there's this one chick man
she's she's heavyset chick um but she
got a wagon like she she's just
she's bottom heavy you know what i mean
but she's still shape
she shaped well you know but she just
was short
thick she that's the best way to
describe her she thick but
damn's chick is saying oh
man dude and then like the way they set
it up with the
you know with katie and them talking to
them about trying to inspire them and
like you know you could do it
you know you you know get out of your
shell and then then the person sings
and and what what comes out of their
mouth and you're like wow
this chick is saying and there's so many
of those this season there's just one
kid his name is willy
big fat dude he's a big dude i mean he's
just a big bonded
dude he went viral singing rihanna a
rihanna song
because i saw this on the episode he
sung he got like it was like millions of
hits of people watching him
sing i gotta tell you there's something
about the timber
in his voice there's something about
something about whatever octave he's
singing in
with the raspiness of his voice and he's
just
on key to tone
is to do he sings like an angel
his name is willie he i mean
but damn he's so big
and when i saw him i was worried for him
you know there's this kind of big
where you see someone and then you and
then something happens to him
and you go well you know what i mean
you just go well i mean it was bound to
happen type of thing
that's how i felt about my friend
ralphie may you know rest
r.i.p but i'll never forget the first
time i met ralphie may
he had just gotten some staple surgery
the staple surgery you know because he's
always been a big fat dude
right and he got dessert and i just
meant it because they just told my
friends that
we were we were doing a show in san jose
this was years ago
and ralphie was at the san jose improv
so we went to go see him we went to go
like because we go they were gonna do
guest sets
this guy luke torres and edwin san juan
i went with them
you know so we had our little like bar
show and then
we did we went to go see ralphie and
they were just telling me he just got
the surgery
when we went into the green room he had
four different fast food restaurant
delivery like just bags in front of him
it was like panda express mcdonald's
chicken place you know and i saw it and
i thought to myself
this dude is gonna die like i really i
never forget that feeling of like
you can't do this to yourself on staple
surgery you know
and it's just one of those things you
see someone at a certain size and you
just go
you're trying to be positive you know
you're trying to have that whole like
oh body positivity which i don't believe
in i'm not i'm not i don't subscribe to
that
that's how you say it um you know and
then you see
you see them and then when something
happens to them you just
you know you just go well i mean if he
had just
fill in the blank you know so ralph he
got sick he died you know what i mean
i don't know the cause but i'm
i gotta think the weight was a factor
that if he wasn't that heavy
listen and i see this kid this guy
willie he's a big dude and then like on
the show
i'm crying cause you know he moved to la
because of the
his video went viral and like he wanted
to be he was like i got to follow my
dream people really think i can sing
millions of people are giving him
comments like dude you gotta this guy is
great
he comes to l.a did he find out his
mother has a stroke so he has to go back
to where he's from to take care of his
mom
and he's a sweet and i totally get that
because it's like my mom and i
i got emotional and then you know and
then you see his mom
who's this big woman who had a stroke i
don't know i don't know the story i
don't know if she had a stroke because
she
of all the weight but you got to think
it's a factor
you know my armchair doctoring i don't
know
and so when i see that and i see him
looking at his mom i think to myself bro
do something about this listen
i am almost 50 years old all right
when you get in your 40s guys you need
to understand something no matter what
you do there's always gonna be something
wrong
it's so weird so like for instance
i lost a lot of weight in quarantine i
started eating better
and just i just lost weight you know i
really changed my diet
but i find out that ain't enough
so you know i go to this place next
health and shout out to next health
because they're about preventative
medicine and i think that's important
i think preventative medicine should be
something that we should all add to
our regimen we should add it to our
lives
it's not just go to the doctor when
something's wrong but hey let's go to
these type of places
to prevent something from going wrong so
i started doing it
but you know i go i take these blood
tests and they find out you know your
vitamin d my vitamin d is too low and
that
affects a lot of things but b12 is low
found out like you know
cholesterol is too high blood sugar's
too high i'm like
i'm like if i don't take care of it i'm
right down the road to diabetes
but i'm sitting here and i'm like but i
lost a lot of weight
aren't i healthy come to find out no no
it's more than just
losing weight it's all these other
things that go into it that are
happening in your body and
as you get older it becomes it becomes
harder
and those things become a larger factor
your gallbladder your
you know the acids aren't functioning
properly so you're not breaking down
foods and your liver you know all these
things and you go damn so i get these
blood tests regularly i'm going in and
talking to them and i'm looking at these
things and i'm like all right i have to
actively work on these things
so when i see this young kid willie i'm
like damn
you know you're young so all this fat
that's on him
he's probably handling it because of his
youth
but as he gets older it's gonna crash on
him and catch up to him and he wants to
be a star he wants to you know be a
singer and he should
listen to me the kid
he has a beautiful voice like
damn every time he sings he you know
along with the story that they're
telling i'm at home crying
and i'm like oh my god and then i'm
looking at him and i'm just like
please let's let's try to get this kid
healthier
he don't got me in shape you know i'm
gonna have a six-pack but just healthier
because it will catch up to him
so you know i'm nervous about that for
him and you know it's a delicate subject
because
listen i'm no expert and you know
there's people that
you know i you know obesity is a killer
man it's
it is and it's it's it's i i think it's
in number one leading cause of death now
i think is obesity i believe i i read a
statistic about this
but you know again don't quote me on it
but um we look it up i mean obesity is a
huge factor
and there's a lot of things that go into
it like everybody's body type and blood
type and
types of food that affect them and you
know it's like we all think it's so easy
oh you just exercise and you feel better
i mean it's like it
it's more to it than that and i know
that because i'm dealing with it myself
but i will say this no matter what stage
you are because
you might see someone and be like well
you have a lot of money so you can hire
trainers or you can go to preventative
medicine places that cost
money regardless of whatever stage
you're at
in terms of like how much money you have
or how much money you don't have
it still boils down to your motivation
to want to be better
because at all levels at all incomes
trying to eat better is possible
okay um
exercise is possible you know there's
there's body weight exercises but you
just need the motivation
that's the first step it is that
motivation that thing to
tell yourself that i want to be
healthier i want to get healthier
and then finding the ways to take the
steps i had this kid dylan dickstein on
the podcast
love him he's a brilliant dude who's
trying to go to mars
you know he's brilliant you know i might
have him on again
he's such a quirky dude but i remember
asking him on my podcast because he said
he used to be a fat kid and i was like
well what did you do
and he it was so simple for him the way
his brain works he was like yeah i
googled how to lose weight
and then i just did all those things and
then when you think about it you go
well damn i guess it really is that
simple
um when you boil it down to that of
being like okay so if the doctor said
hey
if you do these five things
you will lose weight and be healthier
doesn't it sound simple if it's like wow
that's it
you mean eat less you know
so eat less and get some body movement
and you know what all the things are
i mean it's just it is it is that simple
but as a person going through it i know
how hard it is to
make something a habit make something be
to stick and be like stick with this and
make it a lifestyle you know and that's
all we really need to do no matter what
level you're at no matter what income
level you're at or like you know and i'm
sure there's people that say hey man
some people can only afford fast food or
whatever it is like that
i mean even at the fast food places i
mean there's got to be a way to like you
know
i mean you can get grilled chicken at
mcdonald's you don't have to have the
mcdonald's sandwich they got salads they
got
you know i'm not listen you know what i
mean i i mean i'm not
i'm not going to be your financial
expert i mean i don't know people are in
their
their situations and i get it but it
still doesn't stop us from
exercising it doesn't stop us from just
trying our best just making an effort
because that's what it really is about
it's the effort so when people give
excuses about why they can't do
something it is what it is it's just an
excuse
again though i want to speak i'm
speaking from both sides because
i understand because i continually
continue
even now i make the excuse so i'm trying
to find ways to hold myself
accountable so i can stay healthy
so for me the big motivation was oh i
got this show
i'm this size and i'm pretty sure i
wouldn't have got this
part if i was the 40 pounds heavier than
i was before
yeah so now i'm like well i got to
maintain this you know they
i need to and so maintaining is the hard
part it's so easy to gain weight so
that's my motivation and then i have
motivation about you know
i want to if i want to be a dad and i'm
already old
i feel like and i you know i want to
make sure that i'm around so that is
another motivation to be healthy and
then i'm like you know rachel's younger
than me and so i just want to make sure
you know i'm around for as long as i can
be
so you know whatever you could put in
your head to to be the motivating factor
to help you be
a better version of yourself is what you
got to do so anyways
i wish that for this kid on american
idol because i would love for him to win
but there's so many good singers there's
this
young like kitty wears a hat his name is
like hyatt or wyatt he's like a
typical like you know shawn mendes he
looks like shawn mendes you know what i
mean and he's just he plays the guitar
and he's got a beautiful voice and
he's that alternative poppy type guy
then there's like all these soul singers
and they're just great country singers
like i think this is the best group of
talent i've ever seen on american idol
i i don't know how they're gonna pick a
winner but it's gonna be fun to watch
you know so i do
i highly recommend if you like you know
you got nothing else to do and you're
into like singing shows
or watching people like you know grow
this is it right here
so yeah i just
i just hope i just hope that um
i just hope that all these people that
are on the show like there's like a core
of them there's like 10 to 15 of them
that i feel like
are legit bonafide singers it could be
stars
so i hope they stick with it no matter
what happens in the show but damn it was
it's something else man i found myself
being an emotional wreck all right
so there was that american idol make
sure you watch it
what else i've been watching so i saw
the second episode of uh
falcon in the winter soldier loved it
like i love how expensive the show looks
i love all of that i love how
how you know i love how the two actors
are great
you know the winter soldier and the
falcon those two guys sebastian and i
forgot the other guy's name because he's
all over there that guy is in every
netflix show
apparently you know the guy from uh that
plays the falcon
um let me get his name i don't want to
that's just rude
let me let me let me look it up so we'll
look up falcon
winter soldier uh
cast there you go
anthony mackie that's his name anthony
mackie and sebastian
stan they're great together they have
really great chemistry this show is
funny and witty
and it's action-packed you know i i just
love delving into the universe
but it doesn't look cheap like so you
know when they did that um
agents of shield so agents of shield
is supposedly part of the marvel
universe but it didn't look like the mcu
universe
it just looked like a television show
and when you watch a television show you
kind of go
well we know they can't you know they
ain't gonna be able to get
iron man to come on this show you know
what i mean
so it's like you just kind of go it's a
part of it but it's kind of not a part
of it just because
it just looks like a television show
this [ __ ] looks like
a movie you know it looks like they shot
a movie and they cut it up into a
television show
and i just like that you know i've said
that before but
i just really think it's great i just
love i love the interaction i love the
build up i love like just the delving
into this world of like
this is what happened after thanos did
the snap and everybody was gone for five
years and then they came back and like
what would their lives be like
what's going on in people's lives you
know imagine you know your girlfriend
you had a girlfriend or a fiance imagine
you have a fiance and then you
you disappear for five years and you
come back and what she's now five years
older
and maybe she's moved on she got a new
relationship she got a two-year-old now
you know three years after you've been
gone she
she she mourned and she got over it and
now you're back like hey
what's up girl you know it's just like
like how would you do that's a whole
that could be a whole story right there
there's so many countless stories that
they can do
about you know everybody that that
you know disappeared after the snap they
call it you know
or the blip in the show they call it the
blip but
and then they're delving into this thing
about they picked a new captain america
and so that guy which i don't understand
the power things because he doesn't seem
to have any superpowers he even says
that
so i don't know how he's hanging with
when they go they have this big on this
truck
fight and just tremendous special
effects the falcon is flying underneath
the truck and
you know the winter soldier is holding
on and you know
it's great so now there's like these
super soldiers and they got to find out
where
then they go to this other guy this old
guy and you find out that he used to be
a super soldier and they experimented on
him and it's just like you know it's ah
you know i just oh damn i hope i hope
i don't like the fact that they make
these and
what do you call it uh like wanda and
what you call it the wanda one one
division
it was just an eight parter and that's
it it was like the
series finale they said so this was like
if they were going to do a movie called
wanda and vision
they made it they made an eight-part
show 30-minute episodes
so if you think about that you know
that's like maybe what would that be
like a
you know four-hour movie you know what i
mean
that's like so they made a four-hour
movie
and they split it up into 30-minute
episodes
so i just i wonder if this was the plan
too with this winter soldier [ __ ] if it
was just gonna be
we'll do we'll set this up and then
we'll continue it in the movies
or whatever they're gonna do i mean i
just hope that we get to see
i hope they just keep doing this i mean
i really like it
it's just like the mandalorian man i
thought the mandalorian
i really enjoyed the mandalorian i
thought of some of the best star wars
stuff
you know because it's just when you have
a world that's
so big and rich and full of
life like the star wars universe is
then you could just keep making stories
you know
and they've they've proven that i mean
that's basically what
all this is i think
like what really started this
i you know i really think that marvel
the the mcu
universe they made all this possible
like it's because of them that all the
other
all these all these other franchises and
other things that
have nothing to do with disney they're
all like yeah we gotta
we gotta let's make more stories within
this world
i mean even like the hunger games they
could do the same thing
you take a thing of something like that
okay here's the hunger games universe we
already have it created
everybody knows what it is that are into
the movies
we don't need you here for lawrence and
these people let's just go okay here's
another family that's involved with the
hunger games and i think we're okay with
that now
i think i think if you go back to you go
harry potter like when
they took the final book and they split
it into two movies
that was kind of in a way a start of all
this
two because when they did that excuse me
when they did that it was like oh
because because you had to do that i
mean the the final story
can't be an hour and a half you know
what i mean it can't be an hour and a
half
um like
they should have done that for the for
the lord of the rings
i mean they told this whole story but
you know they were following the books
because it was the books in the final
book but like ultimately really
that whole hobbit story the lord of the
rings story of frodo taking that ring
man that could have been that could have
been a freaking eight
season you know hour-long episode eight
season
show right and and the final
return of the king the final uh movie
that sucker was so long i just i i i
can't i don't like a movie being that
long
but they had to make it so long to cram
everything in
and they still miss stuff
so then you cut to now you got all these
you know
we're going to delve into the universe
we're going to like make a multiverse
and so i just i love that star wars
started to do that with the movies but
they just missed a mark
like some of these movies are just not
like that just you know the the
solo han solo one uh
i mean i didn't like that one at all
that one that one wasn't good
i think you know you know there's gonna
be hits and misses right but
i don't know just getting back to it i
just hope that
wherever they're gonna delve into next i
hope that the mcu
marvel cinematic universe continues to
pour
money and resources to make it look
like the avengers movies moving forward
just keep making them look like that and
then that will be
dope all right
oh man what else is going on dude
i guess my mba are you guys into the nba
i guess you guys are
some of you i guess i mean i don't know
it's coming down to the wire now i think
my
clippers my clippers got rondo
so now we'll see if rondo can add that
championship
if he can help push them you know to the
championship
we i just want to see the lakers and
clippers play in a western conference
final
like that would be great but some of
these teams got so much better denver
got better
utah's in the lead you talking about
phoenix is good right now
but you know with the lakers lebron
james and anthony davis are still hurt
so once they come back from injury
will they be able to like get that
cohesiveness going and they just got
andre drummond i feel like from so
cleveland bought him out
and so uh they're going to he's going to
join the lakers
and that's going to be great because
that dude's good like andre drummond's
good
so you're talking about him he could he
could take that spot of dwight howard
and he's even better
and then so he'll start so it's probably
going to be anthony davis him lebron
schroeder and i don't know who the
other guard is gonna be and drawing a
blank on who the other guard is on the
lake so i'm not really a lakers fan
but can lebron james get another
championship so i mean it's really
exciting and then you have in the east
you know i i think something seriously
wrong with kevin durant
uh you know i this has been
quite a bit of time that he's been out
so and maybe they're just not telling us
everything about his
his leg i mean imagine he's probably
probably keeping it hush-hush or
whatever it is because it's a lot of
money invested in the guy
so who knows i wish him the best
and i hope he does come back because i
would love to see
you know whoever makes it to the
championship but ultimately
we want to see the lakers play the
clippers
see who can if kawhi and lebron go
head-to-head
but then at the same time even though i
love the clippers i mean
i just want to see lebron kevin durant
in a championship again
you know with but more a more even team
but i don't even know if it's more even
i mean
you know with um james harden kyrie
irving and
um kevin durant and blake griffin
even though blake griffin's not what he
was
i mean he's still a damn good player you
know what i mean
so good so that's seems like a super
team
still on the level of golden state
so we'll see what happens with these uh
you know when when when these finals
come around all right let me check the
time
all right you know what i think that's
good
you don't always have to be like super
long episodes right
hour i think this has been a good good
amount of time
next week i'm gonna do real world advice
from a grown ass man again i haven't
done that in a while because i just been
busy
i did find someone that is gonna help me
out a little bit so i'm
i got a little intern that we'll see
what he does we'll test him out
on a test uh test basis he's showing me
some of his stuff he's actually a really
great
you know music video director he's a
photographer and he's done a bunch of
good stuff so
we'll see how that uh how that
translates over to the reference griffin
universe
the the art the the rcu
riffing with griffin cinematic universe
that doesn't make any sense but make
sure you watch me game guys
you know come check out error griffin
gaming i'm still gonna do that even when
i do the show
you know let's hope the show gets picked
up though guys i need your energy out
there all right i need the energy
you know i really felt like i i put the
energy out there when i
got this audition you know i was
streaming and i was telling everybody
about it and i had like so every day
my error griffin gaming fans would be
like hey what's up with the audition
griff you know i'm pulling for you
and i really felt like there was
something about that collective energy
that really helped
push me through you know if you believe
in fufu stuff look i got my crystal
right here
so i believe in this too so i'm putting
it out there too in my uh
podcast universe all you loyal fans
because i know you're out there and i
just
i really do appreciate you i don't want
you to think that i don't
you know it's so it's always natural
it's human nature to look at like
the success of others that are doing the
exact same thing and you kind of want to
go well damn i'd love to have a hundred
thousand viewers
but you know i don't want you to think
that i don't appreciate
the ones that i do have because i i
really do i know you guys
you hit me up and you tell me how much
you love the podcast and
i i i really it's what keeps me going
because what other other reason would i
have to
to keep doing this so i do want to keep
doing it i like having this little
outlet
being able to like you know vent uh
just stream of consciousness sometimes
just yip yapping that's what this
episode was just a yip yap
um because i haven't had a guest you
know i might i'm trying to think who i
who i'm gonna have on next um
trying to get bobby on again but he's
like going to do some movie or something
so i don't know if i can get him on but
we'll see i reached out to kalila but
she you know she's busy doing her and
her podcast now and she hasn't even
returned my text
so i don't even know if i'm gonna have
her on um you know we'll find
i'll find someone there's some there's
people out there that i want to get
on just to have a have a conversation
with so
look out for that man well we're still
going and remember what i said about the
patreon you know help me out here i
gotta figure this out
you know should i do just straight up tv
movie reviews
30-minute episodes just for my patreon
viewers who want to come on being a part
of patreon because i just haven't done
enough so people come then they leave
because they're like hey pain you ain't
doing [ __ ]
so i do i do want to start doing that so
hey you guys help me
what's your ideas you guys always got
ideas you always are telling me what i'm
supposed to be doing you guys are
you know the trolls especially
sometimes they come up with good ideas
so let's steal from the trolls and make
this thing work okay
so thanks for watching riffin with
griffin um eric griffin gaming check
that out make sure you share subscribe
like uh make comments let me know what
you thinking and feeling
check out american idol i think i really
think it's good this year it's like a
really talented group
check out a winter falcon in the winter
soldier you got to check that out i mean
i just think it's a
really dynamic show i can't wait to see
uh what's
uh going to happen next and then and
what the marvel universe is gonna do
but this has been riffing with griffin
thank you for watching
and i will see you next week
you